start with the development in Ukraine
where it's been a nerve-wracking night
for locals Ukraine's president zielinski
has accused Russian troops of putting
objects resembling explosives at these
aparitzia nuclear plant that Sky sources
have confirmed a partial withdrawal of
Russian troops from the plant the
ukrainians then issued guidance on how
to leave a zone of radiation in the case
of an accident causing two-mile queues
of people at the border trying to flee
the country
now we have information from our
intelligence that the Russian troops
have placed objects resembling
explosives on the roof of several power
units that the zaparesia nuclear power
plant perhaps to simulate an attack on
the plant perhaps they have some other
scenario but in any case the world sees
can't but see that the only source of
danger to the zaparizian nuclear power
plant is Russia and no one else
oh it's in Odessa for us this morning
what on Earth is going on Dominic
well Kate you have to feel for the
ukrainians to get inside their minds
really imagine the Russians taking
control of one of our nuclear power
stations at the beginning of this war
and then showing no compunction at all
about blowing things up like a dam
causing a huge amount of Devastation
flooding tens of thousands of homes and
then being told by your president last
night that their intelligence their
Military Intelligence believes they've
seen things that look like explosives
being put on the roofs of the reactors
some of the reactors of that power plant
so after a week whether the ukrainians
have been saying that they believe that
the PowerPoint the power plant has been
mined but actually what's been more
worrying I think for the ukrainians has
been what the Russians have been saying
which in the last few days they've been
accusing the ukrainians of planning to
attack the plant themselves and carry
out a dirty bomb incident the reason
that's worrying for ukrainians is that
when the Russians warned the Ukraine is
about to do something it's often a sign
they are about to do it themselves which
they did with the dam they said the
ukrainians were about to attack the dam
and then most western intelligence
agencies believe they then blew it up
themselves so it is the cause of deep
anxiety I think there's some relief that
the night has passed because it the
warnings were about this happening uh
last night what we know about the plant
itself is we're told that the Russians
have moved some people out of the plot
the number of patrols there have been
reduced I think the fear in the minds of
ukrainians is that they're getting out
before they do something to the plant
the good news for the ukrainians is the
international atomic energy agency has
found no signs yet of the plant being
mined but I think even though the night
has passed without incident that anxiety
is going to remain as long as this plant
remains in Russian hands